lafarge is one of my favorite typefaces  people between rides at new york subway  stations are often amused by the  lettered mosaics even the ones who  aren't obsessed with fonts look at this  mosaic in a one-line station that opened  in 1918  to all the creatives on the subway these  letters are captivating  while there are no shortage of nyc  vernacular turned retail typefaces or  even typefaces based on the new york  subway system  by far lafarge is the best  the quirks from the mosaics are adapted  refined and expanded not traced gregory  shutters carefully inspected every  original letter and even synthesized a  wonderful lowercase  like widening and removing the kinks in  s so it would match other shapes other  letters like e he just had to unmosaic  them  that's why